Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question
de Raynald, qui me demande :
« Comment fonctionnent sur les  territoires
des Premières Nations les services qui,
ailleurs, sont fournis
par les administrations municipales? »
Sur une réserve, à cause de la Loi sur les Indiens,
tout ce qui relève des questions fédérales,
provinciales et municipales est pris
en charge par le conseil de bande.
Des fois, il peut y avoir des emprunts de services.
Ça dépend des financements.
Par exemple pour de la police ou du déneigement,
il va y avoir des ententes
entre des municipalités et des réserves.
Mais l'aspect municipal, c'est vraiment
le conseil de bande qui en a charge.
Mais, ça ne veut pas dire
que quand il y a réserve, il y a nécessairement
besoin de services municipaux.
Je pense particulièrement une communauté,
la communauté de Cacouna.
Il y a la réserve, qui s'appelle Cacouna 22,
qui elle, a zéro habitant au mètre carré,
parce que c'est rendu un site tellement petit
que la réserve est vraiment dans une maison
qui est maintenant un centre d'artisanat
et d'enseignement
de la culture des Malécites de Viger.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
de Malécites. Ça veut seulement dire
qu'ils sont répartis un peu partout
au Québec et aussi
un peu plus dans les Maritimes.
Mais pour répondre simplement
à ta question Raynald,
c'est une question qui revient au conseil
de bande. Alors, tout ce qui est
sur le territoire provincial, qui a été mis
de côté pour faire une réserve, tombe sous
la Couronne. Donc, pour la question
fédérale des Indiens inscrits,
il s'agit du conseil de bande.
J'espère avoir pu répondre à ta question,
Raynald, et j'espère que vous allez partager la vidéo
et que vous allez nous envoyer des questions.
Je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine.